uh local elections are on Thursday
joining us to make the liberal Democrats
case is their leader of course Ed Davey
hello to you and it's good to see you as
always now let's talk about Sue gray
should we just start with the um the
arch Inquisitor when it came to
partygate at number 10. um have Labor
got themselves in a pickle or are the
government trying to make too much of it
I genuinely don't know I think there
should be this investigation but I have
to say in all my dealings with Sue gray
I found her a civil servant of the
highest integrity and professionalism so
I suspect there's nothing to see here
but let's have the investigation
um yeah we are expecting to hear later
what the government has found and then
there will be a further investigation as
you said um after that in the meantime
you've got local elections on Thursday
is this not all just a bit of
electioneering
um well we are arguing on the issues
that I think voters are concerned about
whether it's on cost of living with
Energy prices and food prices we've seen
with BP's huge profits the need to put
the liberal Democrat idea first party to
argue for it of windfall tax to help
people with energy bills we're calling
today for a package to help people with
their food bills massive food price uh
uh Rises we've seen and in addition to
the cost of living crisis when we're
knocking on doors talking and listening
to people they're really worried about
the NHS whether it's getting a GP
appointment whether it's ambulance
delays long waiting lists for cancer
treatment and so on so liberal Democrats
have been uh campaigned across the
country on things like the need to help
people with cost living on the NHS
another issue which I think we've talked
about before uh sewage sewage the fact
that the conservatives allowing water
companies to pump their filthy sewage
into rivers and seas so lots of issues
in these local elections as you'd expect
a luckily shop
at the lib Dem saying it's gone up by
about 600 pounds a year but we are um
hearing that although it didn't go up
0.7 last month those prices are going to
start coming down quite sharply very
soon
well people have been saying that for a
little while now uh and I'm afraid uh
your viewers would be forgiven for not
necessarily believing it
um liberal Democrats have said to the
government uh you know you should have
acted on energy bills with the the
windfall tax you should now be acting on
on food bills we've got this proposal
first of all for a competition and
markets Authority investigation into the
supermarkets we've seen the high food
prices uh some of the highest in the G7
in terms of Rises we've seen the big
increase in the profits of the uh
supermarkets so there is a real case for
this investigation alongside our other
measures for example increasing the
number of children who can get free
School meals
why is it taking you so long to call for
this investigation into the weekly shop
cost
well a lot of the things we've announced
today we've been talking about for some
time this investigation uh proposal
we've come out with
um partly links to some of the evidence
that's been emerging particularly how
food prices have been rising faster in
the UK and we what do we want to say to
people today is look we liberal
Democrats have some constructive
policies uh which would really take on
some of these big businesses and you
know the government has failed and on
Thursday on the 4th of May people have a
chance to send a message to the
conservatives they're Fed Up of a
government that's been incompetent
doesn't seem to care doesn't get it is
so out of touch and if people want to
change in many many parts of the country
it's a vote for the liberal Democrats
that can deliver that change